well refugees are also streaming to
South Sudan hanumatasa has more from the
capital Juba
the resources here South Sudan had its
own crisis they saw violence in some
parts of the country and eight agencies
say there's not enough money to help
everybody so what local businesses are
doing at least here in Juba they are
pulling their resources together so you
see in the shops they are collecting
food and medicines and they this these
supplies have been taken to the local
airport they put onto cargo planes and
take them to the border with Sudan to
help people who are still stuck there
South Sudan has a very close
relationship with Sudan this used to be
one country until South Sudan broke away
from Sudan in 2011 and gained
independence but the two companies still
work together president salvakia South
Sudan's leader says that he has close
ties with all the military factions in
Sudan he says he's talking to all the
players every day on the telephone he's
trying to get them to come here to do
with her face-to-face talks trying to
end the conflict in Sudan but right now
of course the concern is the people
trying to come into the country most of
them are from South Sudan so when they
get here they say with family and
friends those who have nowhere else to
go will probably end up at the many
cabins for this place people scattered
across the country it is a huge crisis
for this country with limited resources
as more and more people keep flooding in
well let's bring in Sally mondawi whose
relatives are in Port Sudan struggling
to make it back to the UK she's joining
us from London very good to have you
with us what kind of problems are they
facing Sally
um thank you for having me so basically
I have a three-year-old cousin who's
British national she's with her mum
who's Sudanese National they're refusing
to let them on the plane which is
departing at 12 o'clock she's severely
sick she's supposed to have a
tonsillitis surgery due to it getting
infected but of course with the boy got
canceled she's been in agony screaming
since yesterday so she has to get on
this plane that's leaving in like an
hour and a half and they're saying at
first they told her that she could go on
her own but the mum cannot go because
she doesn't have a Visa which is
absolutely ridiculous this is a life or
death situation if an infection spreads
through your body and you get sepsis you
will die so are they willing to let a
three-year-old child die at the border
because their mum doesn't have a Visa
the whole family has a British passport
except for the mum
can you tell me who it is that is
preventing her from getting on the
flight
so there is a there is
over there they're telling her and even
me I've spoken to the helpline the
crisis helpline and the foreign officers
they've told me that a mum can't get on
she possibly can't get on it's due to
the people on the base the people that
are picking them up it's their
discretion to let her on or not and I
think that's absolutely heartbreaking
where is the humanity in this she's sick
she's three years old and she obviously
needs her mum who she's she's dependent
on
she's been in agony shivering and
screaming since yesterday she's a child
are they there cannot believe him are
they there on their own or are there are
there any other family members around
them
they're completely on their own her
spouse is here in the UK were there
other two kids and they're all British
it's just the mom that doesn't have a
British citizenship are they getting any
help from any Aid agencies or anybody
else at all in Port Sudan yeah no what
kind of conditions are they telling you
that they're facing in Port Sudan at the
moment
and to be honest I've had really quick
phone calls with them and it's all been
about my cousin samarine who's really
sick like the mo the mum is worried
she's she's she was even willing to let
her daughter on the flight on her own so
she could get some medical help she
needs to have a surgery ASAP that's how
desperate she is and they said and then
they changed their mind and they said
she's a miner we cannot let her run you
have to get this so you so they're
willing to let a three-year-old die
basically
if they're suggesting that forgive me
for interrupting you and I do understand
of course this is very distressing for
you if they're suggesting that the um
the three-year-old tell me the name
forgive me tell me the name of the
three-year-old first of all
submarine can you tell me they have said
that samarine and her mother should go
on board a ship as opposed to going on a
plane is that actually an option for
them can they make their way to the port
and get on board one of the ships
with her
with personals and American Nationals
they have not even been able to board
these planes I mean the ships because
there's so much racism at the border
they're only taking people who are
either white or either Saudi or from
other nationalities even that is a
struggle people have slept over at the
Border in dire conditions
these these people are getting treated
like they're going on holiday these
people are ex escaping more the houses
have been bombed
this must be praying
to help
and I again I apologize for interrupting
you but uh this must be praying so much
on the minds of uh her mother can you
describe to us the kind of state of mind
that her mother is in at the moment
when I spoke to someone on the phone
through the crisis helpline and when my
when when her husband spoke to someone
they just hung up on him when he said my
child might die and she said how dare
you say that and she hung up on him we
had to get hold of someone who's a
humanitarian a city needs ago who helped
us called Mia this is the only reason
why I'm on Al Jazeera right now that the
help has been there's no help the mom is
actually feeling really helpless I'm
probably the only person that can speak
clear English and for to represent them
it's really sad like nobody nobody's
listening to them everyone's giving her
different information at the border
I can imagine that you are just one of
many uh Sudanese families who are in the
UK who are facing a similar situation do
you know if there's any sort of support
network or anything for for families who
are in similar situations to yours
if there is any what sorry it could have
um I was wondering if there are any
support networks in the UK that you're
aware of who might be able to help
families who are in situations like the
one you're facing
I mean other than the crisis helpline
where we haven't really had much you
know contact we haven't had any numbers
suggested to us the community the
Sudanese Community has had to come
together and share resources and some
people like Mia has helped me get on Al
Jazeera right now she's been the only
person that kind of could take us
through the law and all the rights the
eligibilities for a British person is
that the spouse or children are allowed
to come with them but when it's a child
with a parent it doesn't it doesn't
apply which doesn't make sense
just very briefly what is your next move
if indeed you feel that you have one
from the situation that you're facing
now
well we only have an hour left for this
other plane to come an hour and a half
and if they don't get on this plane I
don't know what's going to happen like
it's really scary to even think about it
that it won't take her on this plane
because if she even gets the by the
time she even gets to Saudi Arabia it
will be really late and she's already
severely sick
like she's a three-year-old child where
is the mercy where's the humanity
we appreciate you being with us on Al
Jazeera thank you very much indeed for
your time